make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back again with Batman the
conclusion of their dark desires and you
guys really seem to love the video where
Harley Quinn met the Joker's new
girlfriend you guys really seemed to
enjoy that video so in this one we kind
of get the the end of it all right you
know the end of the whole thing or at
least their conclusion kind of starts to
kick off now this does go into Joker war
which is kind of the next big storyline
in the Batman mythos that DC's kicking
around I have no idea if it's gonna tie
into like the three Joker's the
storyline that was teased to us like two
years ago we has never got because hash
tag reasons no idea but regardless for
those of you guys who recall our last
video we basically picked up with Batman
encountering the designer right and the
idea was at the designer it somehow
returned it seemed that he'd been killed
by the Joker or at least by well really
by the Joker and then along with the
other villains who more or less kind of
turned against him but you know the fact
that the designers here now really kind
of gives us a perspective into what's
going on because what you get here is
Batman basically telling the designer
tell me how this goes right give me this
scenario and the designers response is
no like if you've already deduced it
then you tell me what happens and so we
kind of get this big explanation in
terms of how it was all supposed to go
down right so this is how the designers
plan was originally going to unfold in
the city of Gotham before everything
went belly-up with the Joker and all
those guys right so initially the idea
was to bring in five of the highest-paid
assassins the best paid assassins in the
whole world right and at that point in
time back then when this was all kind of
brought together initially right because
the actual plan of the designer took
place in the past it would have been
Deathstroke Deadshot Lady Shiva cagey
beast and Merlin now the whole idea
behind them was to basically launch a
simultaneous attack all at once in the
city of Gotham not against the entirety
of the city's populace but instead
against those individuals who had
basically be in the line of succession
when it comes to the fall of the mayor
right so you'd have the mayor who will
be taken out the deputy mayor the Public
Advocate the city comptroller and the
majority leader of the City Council
right so they would all be taken out in
one fell swoop just all seemingly
happening in almost an instant this
would lead to Batman basically jumping
in and starting to investigate but what
it would also lead to is the penguin
basically becoming mayor of Gotham City
now as the mayor this in turn would move
to the Riddler and the Riddler would
lock down the entirety of the city of
Gotham but what he would do here is he
would operate on two fronts the first
front would be a ruse it would basically
be well there you know
this and all the puzzles and all that
kind of stuff the truth about it was to
basically isolate the NYPD precincts and
then only those individual police
officers who were basically willing to
come forward and swear loyalty to the
Riddler would be allowed to navigate
from one location to the next but what
it would do is it would lock down entire
precincts and it wouldn't make it easy
to take out a multitude of different
cops right because if you don't have to
worry about police officers running all
over the place going underground hiding
different things like that you can just
start taking them out in huge chunks
other precincts don't know what are
happening to other precincts because all
lines of communication are effectively
cut off it would make it easy to
basically take control of the entire
police the entire police force or at
least get rid of those who were who are
not loyal and keep those who were loyal
this goes into Catwoman and because
Catwoman would be the one that basically
be dealing with the money she would
effectively hack into all the various
accounts of the richest man in Gotham
City Bruce Wayne and she would come to
the realization that the Wayne
foundation is actually funded by
offshore accounts and the way this would
work is she would basically have all
those different account numbers in hand
she would drain all those assets and
then redistribute them accordingly based
on whatever the plan calls for but what
it would do is it would basically make
her the richest woman in all of Gotham
and then in turn she would be the bank
for all the various criminals that are
out there the place where they couldn't
they can save their money they can put
their money there and then using those
various offshore accounts she can run
those that run that money offshore and
keep it hidden away from everybody
this finally goes into the Joker and the
Joker's task was simple the Joker would
kill Batman and Robin it's the only
thing that he would do but it seemed to
be the only thing that Joker really
wanted to do and with all of that
happening the designer essentially would
allow the various criminals to take out
and and really conquer the entirety of
Gotham City in one fell swoop it would
happen almost overnight right it would
happen so fast before Batman even
realized what was going on when he first
began the process of investigating they
would be miles ahead of if I D be almost
done with their plan by the time he
first started his investigation into
what was going on now a lot of that was
based on Batman's inexperience at the
time the fact that he wasn't that great
of a superhero I mean he was but in
terms of his detective skills he's
learned a lot over the time that he's
been operating as a superhero and so
they capitalize on that lack of
experience would allow the designers
plan to come to fruition and so
ultimately Batman's responses you know
I'm not the man that I was like I have
evolved I caught up to your design and I
am equal to it now
this leads to the two of them getting
into a kind of sword fight of source now
this jumps back over to to cat woman and
cat will ain't coming to this
realization that they're kind of going
through and accessing these different
accounts that the Wayne foundation is
actually funded through offshore
accounts and it seems pretty shady right
because the way that it looks for
anybody out there the way that it looks
is there just a whole bunch of other
corporations out there or companies out
there who we're all basically working
alongside Wayne foundation and they're
probably looked at as like subsidiaries
or something like that but basically
Bruce Wayne himself doesn't really seem
to own anything in reality it's all
money that's owned by by Wayne
Enterprises but this is also beneficial
because with Bruce Wayne being a person
who operates as a superhero operating as
Batman he doesn't want anybody to know
how that money's being spent and the
truth is that if there was a breadcrumb
digitally or physically in terms of
actual hard cash somebody would come
looking right somebody will be able to
trace that that that breadcrumb and then
ultimately draw the conclusion the
accurate conclusion that Bruce Wayne is
Batman and so in order to remove any
possibility of him being tied to how the
money's being spent with regards to
things going that basically Batman would
use it's kind of a is using a series of
shell companies in order to hide it and
so it's kind of a funny thing because
Catwoman for the most part knows all
this right now the under broker the
person who's you know who's what really
she's not really doing it of his he's
not doing of his own volition like she's
basically told him that she was gonna
dump his identity if he didn't help her
ah but this guy has no idea that Bruce
Wayne is Batman right and his mind is
just this guy's probably up to some
sheets and some seedy stuff and that's
basically it
but regardless the responsive Catwoman
is we're going to drain all these
accounts right like you're going to
drain all those accounts and you're
gonna put them in in my account right
you're basically gonna put these
accounts in my name and I am going to
become the richest person in Gotham now
keep in mind
Catwoman isn't doing this in order to
take revenge on Batman she's doing this
to ensure that Bruce Wayne can remain
Batman and not lose all of his money
right oh that's really the only reason
why she's doing this at this point
remember you know her stance on the
whole planet everything all is kind of
changed over the years and so following
this what we do is we jump to probably
what you guys want to see most which is
Harley Quinn versus punch line now punch
line we don't really know much about her
history her origin or anything like that
but the way that she fights Harley Quinn
really seems to show that she's a pretty
top-notch fighter she's by no means
prodigious right because Harley Quinn's
not the greatest fighter there ever was
right fighting her is not like fighting
Deathstroke or somebody like that but at
the end of the day you know she's you
know having
conversation with punch line talking to
her punch line basically saying that
like at the end of the day Harley Quinn
wanted to fix him she wanted to make him
better why she wanted to water him down
basically into nothing that ultimately
punchline looks at Joker for the way he
is and is in love with it and so the
response of Harley Quinn is you're a
groupie you're basically a Joker groupie
but the idea behind punchline is that
it's not really about that right it's
not really about any kind of physical
gratification that she gets from being
with the Joker if there even is any what
makes him so interesting to her is that
the Joker could conquer Gotham City and
Harley Quinn could have been there for
the entire ride but she didn't want the
Joker for the way he was she wanted the
one of the Joker for the way she wanted
him to be now that wasn't initially how
it all went down but Holly Quinn was
initially in love with the Joker right
that's one of the the many origins of
her character but the long and short of
it is that she always in some form of
fashion was enamored by the Joker the
role he played the way he saw the world
all that kind of stuff and where she was
kind of swept up in that it wasn't until
she began to really see what the Joker
was about that she started to see that
she was better off without him and so as
time began to began to progress you sort
of seen these stories in in in DC comics
where Harley Quinn would leave the Joker
she'd go off and do her own thing the
Joker would run would basically run her
out like he would kick her out she'd go
and do her own thing whatever the case
was she kind of began this process of
separating herself from the Joker more
and more often until eventually she just
walked away why she's basically left the
Joker in his entirety and he just been
operating solo that entire time but it's
kind of crazy because one of the funny
things is that punch line seems to be
highly enamor the same way that Harley
Quinn was and she even goes as far as to
say that like the Joker says I'm the
funniest person he knows well the
response of Harley who's been around
this block more than a few times is like
yeah but he says out to everybody right
like he said that to Batman
he said it to a to an old nun who
couldn't talk anymore like he's the
Joker he jokes like that's what he does
right so if you're really buying into
what he's telling you as an absolute
truth then you're an idiot like he's a
bad guy right like he's a villain and
the responsive punchline is maybe he is
you know and maybe he will hurt me one
day but I'm gonna hurt you first she
manages to get the upper hand on Harley
and then slices her throat following
that they toss her body into the water
and then she in turn starts to go after
a source to go after Catwoman it's kind
of crazy to see punchline take out
Harley Quinn that way but picking back
up with Batman and the designer again
the two of them sort of going out and
continuing to fight so on and so forth
one of the things that Batman figures
out is that the designer had
underestimated Gotham City right to the
designer
believed he could just kind of roll in
here and basically start pitching these
ideas these various criminals on ways in
which they could topple Batman and Robin
and then take the city for themselves
but the reality is that the designer
underestimated the Joker ne
underestimated Gotham City given this
plan and the nature of what it is that
he wanted to do at the end of the day it
would only really work if Joker was
willing to kill Batman and Robin well
the truth is that the Joker didn't want
to he wanted to kill everybody else but
he didn't want to kill Batman and Robin
and it scared the crap out of the
designer because the Joker couldn't be
explained
he couldn't be rationalized right he
couldn't be categorized he wasn't
somebody that was just based on simple a
simple desire to acquire money or
anything like that right like it's like
the Dark Knight he just wants to watch
the world burn and that's really what
the designer didn't grasp when the judge
when the designer first showed up here
he thought the Joker was just a petty
serial killer right and like appeals to
his to his vanity or to his desire to
acquire wealth or to vengeance by taking
out Batman and Robin would be all he
really needed to be on board but when
the Joker was was brought in by the
designer and the designer learned what
the Joker was really about that he was
really just a madman he was an
absolutely insane person he didn't care
about the identity of Bruce Wayne and
Robin I'm sorry about man and Robin he
didn't care who they really were
he didn't care about killing them that
in fact he wanted to keep them alive and
just make them suffer like killing
everybody else the designer realized he
was beyond any real ability to be
reasoned with and so ultimately this
cost the designer his life and when
Batman pulls off the mask the designer
is actually dead right he's basically
just kinda like this shambling shell is
Batman refers to it and ultimately he's
being controlled by the Joker
and that's when Batman asked the
question what are you doing like why
attack me like this what are you trying
to prove now Batman have figured out the
Joker was controlling the designer
seemingly some time ago is not really an
indication of that's that's actually
true but probably partway through this
fight he seemed to figure it out and the
response of the Joker is like it's not
my plan to break you right that's what
comes next like I have a whole year to
do that right so you know obviously
teasing Joker war but his whole idea is
I needed to break her in order to break
you right so in turn like that man
realizes its Catwoman that he's going
after and so immediately Deathstroke
jumps in try Deathstroke was tasked by
the Joker for completing a task
Deathstroke managed managed to sneak
into this place or managed to get into
this place would Batman distracted and
in that moment stabs him through the leg
with a sword and normally it wouldn't
really matter
but the idea here is that if batman
pulls it out he's gonna bleed to death
right so basically he's basically kind
of stuck here at the moment and he has
to figure out what it is that he needs
to do next right like some kind of a
medics gonna have to be sent over here
by by Lucius Fox there is no Alfred
anymore right so it's like Alfred can
tend to his wounds or anything so
Batman's got to figure out what to do
and in that time he needs to figure out
what it is that he needs to do that
allows the Joker's plan to continue
going and that's the benefit of all this
right it's not really the grandiose
nature of the plan that provides its
success its the precious moments in
between each step to provide success
right the fact that Batman has to stop
and figure out what he's gonna do for
like five or ten minutes is all the time
the Joker needs to achieve a particular
goal that's really what you're talking
about here right as fast as the mind of
Bruce Wayne works his ability to react
almost instantly right whatever that
case is this means the Joker has to be
able to respond accordingly and all this
stuff seems to have been prepared for
and so switching back to Catwoman once
this is all done and Cattleman's work is
finished and all this money has been
transferred to essentially another
external account then the responsive
Catwoman is remove all my information I
delete all my account information all of
it has to go and at the end of the day
the response of the under broker is well
I mean your account like your account is
actually quite empty right like you
believed you were transferring all this
information to your account and you
believe that what we were gonna do now
is remove your account from this
database so nobody else could access it
but there's nothing sent to your account
your accounts dead because you were
never sending money to your account in
the first place without happening
there's a gunshot we end up finding out
punch line pulled the trigger Catwoman
is essentially down for the count and
then in turn she calls the Joker and the
Joker asked the question is it done and
she says yes and the Joker says say it I
want to hear these words and the
response is Joker you are now worth over
100 billion dollars without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
purse
[Music]
you